crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday you
already know though
Ryan's a soccer star JUCO above-ground
cool goes better than most Jay Larson
self-diagnosed go down low this week
last week here we don't forget the crab
feast
welcome back to the crab feast y'all
know the Tuesday another crappy mmm I
felt that at the end I felt like there
was just a touch off and I just went a
little bit in there touched it went to
it I went for that second second you
know what I mean yeah it's like a
two-plus gear inking good to see you
good to be here with you sickle cell
peace nation great to be here with you
as well as long as Jay Larson commie
comm Jay Larson common across all social
media if you wish to reach out hear
about any shows no shows to promote for
me there's a couple in town dates but
I'll just tweet them up the day before a
day of except for sickle cell and I will
be at the nerdmelt theater on Saturday
the 3rd of October telling a story
together Rai said to me the other day
text me like you what story retell I'm
like I don't know he's like don't you
think which rehearsed that and then
we'll figure it out but I say rehearse
yeah you said don't you think what do
you say I don't know I'm not putting it
past me but I feel like rehearsals
overdoing the Sal of sicko
Ryan Sickler on Twitter and are you done
yes I am sir all right Thank You Ryan
Sickler on Twitter and Instagram Ryan
Sickler official on Facebook Ryan so
calm for my any dates and info the crab
feast calm for all your craft fees info
I wanted to tell you give you a heads up
now we will be supporting breast cancer
awareness again next month we will be
fully stocked on all merchandise and as
we did last year this year again
percentage of all merchandise because we
have sold out of the Tuesday breast
cancer shirts a percentage of all
merchandise will be donated to breast
cancer awareness so help us promote
breast cancer awareness next month
what about koozies anything and hurts
all merch hensel's two mugs pencil -
yeah pencils we have perfect pencils and
thank you for all the ways you all
support the podcast the amazon link is
huge help the new premium episodes you
guys are lighting that up right now
that's live from the 2015 Bridgetown
Comedy Festival with Dana Gould and Ian
Karmel it's a great episode as are all
of them and they are available on iTunes
and for androids and non iTunes users on
Gumroad and they're only a dollar
ninety-nine two bucks two bucks
love seeing you all
out there communicating on the Facebook
Fanpage communicating y'all I love
seeing the i-tunes five-star reviews you
guys are the [ __ ] best follow all
things comedy on social media let me ask
you something guys are you the guy or
girl in your group that's fresher than
everybody else this week touch of
moderns here to tell you that there's
one trendsetter in every group someone's
got the late ladies clothings the
coolest gears and newest products is it
you I don't know are you ready to
upgrade your style without upping the
price touch of mine come has all the
latest trends at the best prices
why and how you ask well I'll answer you
touch Ahmad and connects directly with
top designers they have timeless and
unique products each item is hand
selected to grab your attention which in
turn grabs other people's attention and
all at unbeatable prices Ryan I've said
it before we love the site we think it's
awesome that's why we're glad to have
them on as a sponsor and look at it
daily always it is it's like another
social media thing you look at because
they always have cool things and even if
you're not buying it it just ups your
mind of like oh look at this let me
think about that but don't think too
long because they're gone within a day
it's not only that do you know how many
times I've said out loud looking at
stuff like I don't even know they made
this yeah like who came up with this and
you're a trendsetter and and on your own
right
jaw-dropping tech gadgets in gear sleek
iPhone case and accessories eye catching
new and vintage watches I mean name it
it's on there guys with sales literally
launching every day touch of modern calm
is the one website to discover and
elevate your lifestyle and a single
click so right now our listeners can get
immediate access when they sign up at
touch of modern calm that's touch Aman
com do it today because tomorrow it's
gonna be different that's how life rolls
in the fast lane and speaking of the
fast this guy roll I mean he runs the
fast lane he is the fast lane he's also
the slow lane and he's here today to
take it easy easy easy please welcome
for the first time to the craft fees mr.
Randy licky welcome to the crafty
Scrappy's Randy thanks for being here
and you seem genuinely excited to have
you here man
before we get
scuse me before we get rolling why don't
you let everyone know everything you
want them to know about Randy looky
where they can find you see y'all that's
oh goodness like my twitter account all
of it okay
all the boy I have a Twitter account
it's my name
Randy Lipke Li EDT ke the D it's how you
spell it and you know I have a website
but it's not very important I have a
podcast it's also on all things common
for all the bone zone
yeah and Brendon Walsh and I we host
that I've been doing it for a while
check it out it's a fun one it is a fun
one and I mean that's I mean should i
plugging things is that at the end or
yeah whatever you want to plug I have a
half-hour come right now yes
October 10th is when it's gonna air perf
and that on that same day my album will
be released all nice in association with
my half-hour look at the the albums
called I'm on a roll and the cover is me
laying on an open-faced hoagie sandwich
and we're just we're just doing the
artwork for that right now so it's still
in the works but October 10th you can
access all of that nice man I know my my
uncle had a business called on a roll oh
really and he that's what he did then he
made sandwiches oh really like a MTO
sandwich shop now wasn't a sandwich shop
he was basically a he made but made a
commissary so he would supply like food
trucks and you know when you're going to
like a Ralph's and you're like aw let me
grab this pre-made sandwich that was him
you know what his big selling point was
what those that meat never left a
freezer freezer like when they made
those Sam shoes they were in a wok and
making them inside there so they were
always and then transported right into a
freezer truck man that's like the
opposite of never frozen
it's the always right now freeze room
it's not frozen it's a you know walking
forgiveness of frozen turkey it's not
frozen so it's just refrigerator but
it's never like you know everywhere cold
[ __ ] yeah okay some of this guy by
the way he started a business like okay
he had like a deli like corner shop this
is who
it's my uncle okay not an uncle you know
like the aunt and uncle that aren't
related but you call him out you grew up
with him and everything yeah I think we
all know that yeah this guy was but
there's still the best the couple first
one went under started a second one went
under started all sandwich stuff yeah
started another business like this like
the commissary went under finally got it
right
he sold that so that company called to
Google so they'll go for big dollars
city big dollars I'm talking one two
three six eight figure broken just pay
it all and still the most down-to-earth
level dude you'll ever meet in your life
that's great always frozen always frozen
you know so hey never frozen bro you so
do you need a water sure could we get
please Mike could we get Randy a water
so just check out an appetizer menu I
just I I mean we're talking about that
stuff so I wanted to do talk to you well
you're from Oregon originally grew up in
Oregon yeah I lived in a lot of
different towns there but mostly Oregon
why did I move around my dad worked for
Oregon State Forestry
oh really yeah what does that entail
that around well he grew up in LA and
then he like he was like a Boy Scout you
know yeah and he liked the outdoors and
you know he liked camping so he thought
he wanted to be like a park ranger or
something so he went to forestry school
in Arizona because he thought that meant
like he didn't know what it meant he
thought it would be like a camping guy
yeah like a like a ranger
I got a master's a camping yeah I don't
know
and so right out of college he got a job
in Oregon that's where a lot of the
trees are yes and worked there ever
since he just retired recently so he he
worked his way up the ladder working for
the state and we moved like taking care
of the trees or in the end it was mostly
a management job so like it was it was
forest fires a lot of the times dealing
with lumber companies overseeing yeah
man I never forget the first time I went
to Oregon and I'm driving is like
beautiful and also you just hit and it's
just field of cut down trees
like whoa like it's you know it hits you
you know I mean I pulled over I walked
through it it was it was weird clear-cut
yeah well and people say that that's
terrible
and it's actually because like the other
ways of cutting down trees is just like
walking through and cutting down like
every third or fourth tree but you can't
regrow them yeah because they don't
they're in the shade when they're
saplings so the clear cut is the only
way to regrow a whole field at once I'll
never forget while I was up there I saw
a sign said John lidtke clear-cut 2003
man I think that was his platform wasn't
it but he wouldn't you know he didn't he
didn't work for a lumber company his job
was to like state forestry is private
land and in Forest Service's federal
land so his deal was like if a fire was
on land that people owned whether it be
a lumber company or actual person who
just owns a house that happens to be on
a lot of land so you know they weren't
like making money off of cutting down
trees they just had to deal with all the
general yeah and like a lot of times if
there was like a flood or some other
type of you know bad thing that happened
in Oregon they would hire my dad and
other people to manage that situation
because his job was always like oh [ __ ]
there's something bad happening alright
you do this you do this you know
everyone go to this place so it was all
about managing people other than trees
were you boy scout I was for like my
brother got Eagle Scout which is the
bestest topic yeah yeah first of all you
get a letter from I was a boy scout I
went to star my brother was like Eagle
you get a letter from the president man
that's all I'm saying you can scout his
badass how far were you as the star from
Annie Ghost our life eagle but the DOE
your brother would did one level higher
than yeah he get it level higher than I
did well there's a lot in there there's
more than that it's like it's like Scout
is the first one on a roll but a second
class first class then Tenderfoot then
star Tenderfoot sounds terrible and then
you're letting your feet and then like
there's like yeah there's like three
more and then Eagle star life Eagle or
something I mean I were you bro I I got
the second class
why don't I don't feel like I still got
a yellow scarf man I don't need to dip
it I decided like Cub Scouts
and then we blows and we lived in a
different town when my brother was like
becoming an Eagle Scout and my dad was
the Scoutmaster in that town and then we
moved my brother graduated high school
that's what I want to ask well how old
are you like if you start whatever how
old are you by the time you get to me
are you a high school kid and you might
be in high school you have to be you're
not like a senior in high school no like
when I stopped doing Boy Scouts I was a
sophomore in high school
yeah that seems about right but like I
could get I knew there's no ten-year-old
Eagle Scouts out there no but there
might be someone Jake yeah I knew a kid
that was like 12 or 13 that that fast
tracked it I mean one of these there's
so much you have to do to get eagle but
then like then you have to do your Eagle
Scout project which is like you're like
grad school thesis you know and you have
to do like I remember one kid he dug an
entire ditch in our town and filled it
with rocks so that water could drain
like made a drainage system for this
part of town that was like over flooding
and stuff didn't work he'll four people
four people died would've been five be
saving merit back my brothers was we
just had to like we did some trail work
we like we rebuilt a couple like
turnarounds on like a trail on a cliff
or whatever and it was like a lot of
work for a car or a human for my evey
hiker hiking yeah so we had to like
build a bunch of rocks into the side of
a cliff yeah you know when you're going
hiking like around to mescal and you're
like man this is risky but there's like
wood in there and someone built steps
and those are Boy Scout Scouts
that's tight man so we did that my dad
was like the leader and then my my
brother was out of it before we moved so
that he would've been a freshman in high
school when he got his Eagle and then we
moved to a different town and then I was
plugged into like a different troop and
I didn't really like like I liked a few
of the people I didn't really like the
leaders and like a lot of the people
that were in it I got into like a good I
remember it was called but within the
troop there was smaller groups and I
liked those guys and my dad wasn't
really like that involved because
everyone else so I didn't like it as
much
yeah it wasn't as fun right and so I
just I just went on the trips and had
fun
didn't like it wasn't striving to like
earn badges and snow/ice went to the
camps and had a lot of fun and and and
they were like yeah that's fine
you don't you know my dad was an Eagle
Scout so it was kind of like this thing
that we were doing but then so like one
bald eagle one thing that I say even
hire me to like defend myself from being
like yeah I wasn't into it
was one of the guys that was in our
troop by time I was a junior sophomore
junior in high school he went to jail
for murder whoa he was a like you mean
six freshmen or sophomore there's a
thing that happened at my high school
for was four boys and two girls all
murdered one of their mom's let's pump
the brakes here hang on what are you one
of their mom's daddy so like one of the
kids what high school did you go can you
you can obviously talk about to Redmond
High School in Redmond Oregon okay and
and you're at the time this happened
you're a sophomore in high school I was
probably I may have been a junior and
one of the kids was a senior did you
know any of them personally or I mean I
knew the kid from Boy Scouts I didn't
and his mom she make up gay no father
for Christ so wasn't it wasn't his mom
it was one of the other kids moms and he
he killed another person's mom so like
one of the guys who was the senior I
forget his name but he was like let's
murder my mom for it okay he's the
ringleader against his own mom so yeah
yeah and his his mother was really good
friends with a lady that my mom worked
with so like four years my mom heard
these stories from her co-worker about
like oh yeah her her friends having a
real hard time with her son I think she
goes to your high school or whatever so
I grew up in a pretty small town but our
high school still had I was still
considered one of the bigger schools in
the state cuz we had one high school in
my town so like I graduated with like
300 kids yeah it was like a normal sized
school that
bigger that's twice the size of my okay
yeah so we have more murders than the
one I went to I could say that right
right Matt yeah so the story is you know
this guy like whatever he hated his mom
and his mom was a sweet nice lady but he
was like a weirdo and as they dug and
found out more about it like he had all
these like fake websites these like fake
death metal metal bands where he would
write lyrics he was didn't play any
instruments but he would just write
these weird murder lyrics and he was
huge following huge Fahlman and he would
started Twitter he would like get on
chat rooms that he knew his mom was on
his mom was like a single mom and he
would like harass her as someone else
they found out later so he was like he
was a weirdo yeah and so he had these
friends one of them used to be in that
Boy Scout Troop that I was in one of
them was kind of like a guy that we we
always were like yeah guys I left out he
was like a weirdo always in trouble
maybe I think I played football with him
in middle school so we all knew who he
was but he was a kid that was always
kicked out of school and just crazy guy
and that may have been all of the boys I
think that's all the boys and there was
two girls dancing that part is a I mean
this is so crazy but to be two girls and
mrs. Quinn they were like you they were
freshmen so I think it was like a
sophomore or junior senior and then like
two fifteen-year-old girls and they were
all like hanging out and like drinking
and doing drugs or whatever and they
stopped going to school and they were
kind of like considered runaways and
they were living in hotels and we were
they getting the coin I have no idea but
maybe they were stealing it oh man pine
box berries left and right man standing
like Motel sixes and stuff and it
probably is and then they go they they
had heard that it was legal to smoke
weed in Canada so in like at this point
Vancouver did have Eris's what years are
we talking about here so this is 2000
and so they said why don't we go up to
Canada because you can smoke weed there
and they were like so excited about that
and they said well let's go like the
main guy was like let's go to my house
my mom's at work and we'll you know
we'll take her car we'll steal her car
or was it no they had her car that's
what it was they had her car let's go
there let's take as much as we can from
the house money different things stock
up eat some food and then let's head to
Canada so they drop smoke weed to smoke
weed this is really this is like wow
they were children you don't I mean if
they just waited 14 years it's legal and
[ __ ] poor I know they're sitting in
jail and so they get to they get to the
house they like you know they trash the
place and then when it comes time to
leave the guys like I can't find the
keys to the car we've lost the keys we
can't get out of here we're screwed and
they're like well what do we do your
mom's gonna come home we trashed the
place
so he's like wow I guess we have to kill
her and so later what you know when it
went to the court and everything a lot
of people were trying to prove this was
a plan by this guy he you know he's okay
he wanted to kill his mom and this is
how he got people to help him do it but
the power of him too that's what's
amazing to me that dude could have he
could have been president if he turned
that [ __ ] to a positive way he got four
people to help him kill somebody yeah
and then that's unbelievable yeah I mean
it gets crazier because they were like
well how are we gonna do this so they
had set up the house in all these
different ways to kill her where they
didn't have to do it we're nowhere they
were just like well what if she gets out
over here we got wasn't no surprise so
they have like childish ass like you
know they had hair dryers plug they
filled up the bathtub they had all the
electronics plugged in in the bathroom
they they they put bleach in a syringe
oh my god they had you know they had all
these wine bottles ready to like beat
her up with they had all these like
things ready and I guess you know they
were beaten up worth wine bottles until
the one guy was like this is the guy
that was in my Boy Scout Troop was like
all right this is you guys this is
[ __ ] up so he shot her to put her out
of her misery and they were beating her
with wine bottles death yeah yeah and so
then he heard this great wine up an
Oregon Pinot Noir up there no country
yeah he was the one that pulled the
trigger you know a lot of the focus was
on this dude but he was just like he was
a hunter it was a mercy it was like he
was like I've been hunting and I just
needed to put her out of her misery
these people were destroying her you
know oh my god so that you know and
there was a lot of really good newspaper
articles after the fact kind of
recounting this like every week they
would have like this really in-depth
look at it because you know a couple of
the parents have one of two of the kids
would be like now he's the one that
pulled the trigger and the other people
would be like yeah but he is the
mastermind he planned this he took
advantage of this kid he didn't want to
be there he he was tricked into thinking
that he had no way out this is his only
way to not get in trouble you know
so that damn ember that day at school
because it was like school was on
lockdown yeah they're like some shit's
going on everyone state you know locked
the doors no one's good because they
thought they would show up at school and
then and then they got stopped at the
border in Canada so they killed her and
left and then got stopped yeah so they
were like we have to kill her because
then we can take her car keys and take
her car that's what it was they had
someone else's car we lost the keys now
we have to kill her take her car so they
get stopped at the border and they're
like yeah we knew you're coming up here
we got grey weed Wow
yeah and in jail yeah yeah so my parents
are kind of like all those kids so that
the girls got like 25 years and the
other three got life without parole
wholly shame yeah and I was like do them
and their kids got great children tried
as adults like yeah uh-huh yeah yeah I
mean it was I I remember maybe a year
ago kind of there was a documentary that
come at came out if it was called I
think when I watched it was called
something you know they changed the name
eventually it was all about I think I
haven't been called kids who kill at
that point
but now maybe it's called life without
parole or something like that I all I
now that you brought it up I remember
this because it did call attention to
how great the line was sideways these
kids weren't in that documentary but it
made me remember I was like oh [ __ ]
normal even that happened and I was like
they're still in jail yeah like they
left it like the 15 year old girls
they'll get out at 40 and and still have
an entire life to live knowing that
don't forget that wasted it helping
someone kill someone you know anyone in
high school who's like totally into
drugs almost totally [ __ ] up and then
they clean up and you see him at the
college you know dude what's up and like
yeah I just got my life together these
kids could turn out to be like amazingly
super sweet nice that were just all lost
and they're gonna come out I mean except
for the dude who planned it you know I
feel like one dude who planned it was
[ __ ] up he needed you know he clearly
needed some sort of help other kid was
just he was a maniac like our whole
childhood was like yes don't even say
anything to him he's a weirdo yeah like
they'll punch you for no reason not that
he was like could beat you up but he has
nothing to lose and then the other guy
was just like a sweetie
got wrapped up into some [ __ ] and then
made a [ __ ] terrible decision oh and
that was the kid that was in my and he
probably was as a hunter was probably
looking it at it like it was an animal
yeah well and then and then like when
they got arrested the guy whose mom it
was was wearing the shell of the bullet
on a necklace wait what so the guy so
clearly he wanted his mom dead he was
like he was this whole weird thing that
he was like loving and what happened he
we who was wet wait said the kid whose
mom it was the mastermind right had the
shell he was wearing the bullet yeah he
made a necklace out of the shell of the
bullet that killed his mom Jesus Yeah
right so this day I was like oh [ __ ]
they're still in jail I looked them all
up because you can go to learn Facebook
yeah they probably I do have a prison
Facebook though they have like you know
you can go to the State Penitentiary and
website you can look up an inmate by
their name and
their most current mugshot so it was so
weird says like yeah last time I saw
this guy he was 15 and at watch them be
like oh now he's a big strong dude
that's been in prison since I last
thought about him yeah oh so we [ __ ]
prison the only thing worse than I in
this wasn't my high school but a town
like 25 minutes north of where I grew up
one year nine girls got together and
made a pregnancy pact that they would
all get pregnant remember hearing about
that wait this is your school no
Gloucester High School in LA excuse it's
like 25 miles north of where pregnant
get pregnant and they all did nine of
them they all got pregnant somebody like
45 year old dude somebody that
boyfriend's yeah they they just like oh
this would be a great idea dumb [ __ ]
but they just wanted to have a kid I
guess
and then once two of them are doing it
like the other the opposite of your
story completely they made that is
[ __ ] nuts man don't you wish there
was an adult Boy Scouts you know I mean
we just went camping and like you had
cool thing you could shoot archery for a
while yeah
like a camp like a camp like a week-long
summer camp for yeah dude I don't know I
came for a dog just go do that well you
could do that without the uniform when I
was a kid like yeah I know we can't do
with like tons of dude the great thing
is it you this is the thing you forget
like that people you know like when you
don't play sports anymore you're never
gonna play organized sports again where
there's a league and there's refs and
this coaches and it's like you're
working towards something
the thing with Boy Scouts and the
difference being just goin campin
somebody's is with Boy Scouts you'd be a
camp and they'd be like all right we're
doing this you do you know you're
working towards things yeah I just feel
like as a kid I was more open to meeting
big groups of new people and like now if
I was like yeah you're going to this
camp you only know a couple people I'd
be like that sounds like a nice blend in
and make friends if you like I know I
don't give a [ __ ] Larry I don't give a
[ __ ] at you tie the arrow getting
bullied yeah doughnuts well I want to
talk to I want to move on from high
school because you said you had an
interesting first job
of high school and I would love to hear
well my first job it was I was still
living in Central Oregon and it was you
know a summer job before I went to my
freshman year at college and it was my
friend's dad owned a gas station which
was not a truck stop but it was like a
gas station that had a mini-mart in it
like a Sheetz Wawa
I don't know what those are better am
pm's yeah I mean this was like a Shell
station but it had you know I had a
little market and I had a little deli
food area and yeah they hired me there
and I worked in the deli at that point
it was a Chinese food first of all how
can I got a how can you call yourself a
deal food at the belly so I guess in the
north in the northwest we use the word
deli differently I think clearly because
like the Chinese did in where you guys
are from New Delhi like there's all
these little markets that sell Boar's
Head sandwiches yeah like made MTO
sandwich yeah and then there's also like
real you know like Katz deli and that
type of like real big things with lots
of bravado to me I don't know in Central
Oregon a deli was like a gas station
they said we got a deli and it was like
fried corn dogs and pizza pockets and
burritos and jalapeno poppers it was
like a place then oh no but it was like
a hot case with just like tons of fried
food in it chicken strips and I guess
7/11 now yeah but like on a grander dad
oh yeah so this place still had one of
those it had you know like whatever
these all this frozen fried [ __ ] and
then the other case was all Chinese food
like pre pre cooked Chinese food like a
Panda Express or something and you could
you know you get like I'll have a three
item combo with half chow mein half rice
give me some chicken teriyaki some hard
[ __ ] some pizza box
totally
come in and the story behind and yes
yeah it was like it was like dudes would
come in and buy their packs of
cigarettes for the day and then just get
you know some egg rolls and [ __ ] but the
story behind it was the owner I won't
name any names for this one that's fine
but the owner had hired this guy to
start the Chinese food stuff there and
was you know promised him a bunch of you
know was it a Chinese guy yes so he was
like he was like you'll run it within my
thing but I will pay you profits you
know I'll give you a cut of the profits
rather than just paying you and it'll be
like your business inside of my business
and this is all what I heard you know
sure maybe maybe this isn't true and
then he kind of screwed the guy over who
did the owner screwed the the Chinese
cook over and and wasn't doing that so
then the Chinese cook said oh yeah well
I'm gonna go across the street and open
up my own Chinese restaurant and he did
did he
and then no gas camp and Express I can't
get gas there and then the guy that
trained underneath the original chef was
a Mexican chef so he was a Mexican guy
and you know his name was Miguel I'll
name that name because you know I could
and he just ran the same business you
know it didn't have to pay him any type
of you know cut to the profit or
anything and that's when I worked there
was like you know the Chinese chef
Miguel the second regime was there and
my job you know I worked with has a big
black lady that would like rub my
shoulders all the time what you say
every time somebody works and a kid ran
around food just massaging face where
one of my duties was I would mmm I had a
digital timer that I would set for every
5 or 10 minutes I can't member and when
it would go off I would have to stir all
the Chinese food so it didn't form a
skin mm-hmm and the handles of the
spoons were plastic and they would get
super hot and he had we had to wear new
rubber
for every transaction and it which is
like the heat would like hold in the
rubber gloves and just like burn your
hands it was a it was a cool job
I got a how how great was the place
across the shinies a huge he didn't
drive the gas station no no he was just
like I want to have a Chinese food
business and I thought this is my way of
doing it but you know I'll just go do it
over here and then I mean that the the
world of this gas station was even it
was crazier because the owner was he was
my friend's dad and very eccentric and
and weird and he and he had turned he
turned the the walk-in cooler so there
was like a walk-in cooler we could go in
and where things are always frozen right
it was it was for the customers where
they have cases of beer yeah so you know
they had like the walls of glass doors
because I love that I know I love when I
go back to Baltimore and I go in a
liquor store and I go back to the back
of the store and there's no way out of
that room it's just a freezer and you
open it up and you go in and people are
you doing I'm like I'm going to get a
cold case of beer right now yeah I love
that you can go in this I love their
little tight yeah I love that [ __ ] so
but they had done for this was they they
took paper mache and they built it to
look like a cave so the entrance to the
walk-in cooler was this big cave
entrance and on the inside that was
stalagmites and stalactites and he even
put for some reason he put this is when
castaway was popular he put one of those
volleyballs in there
Wilson was on there he called it the
beer cave and it said bear and the bear
was crossed out and he bought a
taxidermied bear come on and he put it
by the entrance to this guy's afforded
by the entrance and he'd put a Hawaiian
shirt sunglasses and a fishing pole on a
case of beer and also there
the beer cave and one of my Jobs was
when he was a friend of Mines younger
brothers outfits once we grade each one
of your outfits in you're the only one
that says there's one of my friends
younger brothers that did the bear it
was like his first taxidermy problem
wondering how much the bear set a back
that can't be cheap to buy a taxidermy
bear I'm thinking I'm thinking 10 bills
they had the kid from the murder shoots
bear but my I remember the hit he didn't
have the bear yet and he wanted to build
the bear standing on a big rock so he
was like we need a big rock have you
seen any big rocks and I was like no you
know I have it
and he said I think I saw one one of the
other businesses they ran out of the gas
station was like he would rent Ryder
trucks like u-haul trucks off the same
property yes we had got her inside the
same business that would that would rent
Ryder trucks so he would just took one
of the Ryder trucks he's like come with
me take off you know your apron and your
uniform shirt bring the gloves man kind
of want I don't want people to know that
you work here you know okay we're gonna
go steal a rock right and we just like
drove up this like country road until he
sobbed meanwhile he's in like Larry's
gas station pickup truck the whole way
and and pulled over and was like go get
that rock I don't you know he didn't
know if it was legal we were stealing a
big rock so I think could you ask your
dad if it was legal what a deadly no no
he's not a rock and so I had to carry
this giant rock and throw in the back of
a Ryder truck and then he drove it back
to the station and then my job for the
rest of the day was to wash the rock he
gave me this wire like month so it was
covered in dirt but he wanted to paint
it gray the color of a rock I think it's
already yeah it's a rock but he didn't
want the dirt on that Ksenia to paint it
so I spent like two hours with like a
you know a wire brush on the end of a
stick come on
sitting in a brought the hose sitting on
the ground
washing a giant rock and dudes with
drive-by dude makes fun of me how big
was it it was it was like three feet by
three feet it was a big rock I mean we
you like struggling to lift that thing
yeah it was it was big like Central
Oregon is like the small Boulder yeah it
wasn't as tall maybe as it was three
feet by you know less than three feet
but it was like a lava rock so it was
very flat you know in Central Oregon
it's very it's a volcanic area got it so
it was this big flat rock that I had to
wash all day
this guy misses calling this guy should
have worked like Disney or something up
rides and stuff well this guy I mean I
haven't even gotten to the best part
this guy mm-hmm he would get very
obsessed with things kind of month by
month and while I worked there it was
mannequins he was really into buying
mannequins and dressing him up like they
worked there he'd put him around the
corner and you'd get all freaked out you
know that my wife means for me all the
time this car dealership off the 101
have you seen it with a the mannequin
hilarious so weird but that's what you
were doing before I started working
there he was really and for some reason
fixing up Model T's but like he wasn't a
car guy like he just had some car that
he would put the key in he'd break the
key off and then he would never have to
have a key again cuz he can just walk in
and turn it on he wasn't a car guy but
yet he figured out like a cheap way to
fix up these old Model T's so he had him
all over the parking lot with mannequins
in them at one point he put like a lady
mannequins leg like hanging out the back
until his son had to be like I don't
think that's a problem I don't know one
thing you have back of the truck the the
Model T yeah like like like a guy who
like bagged a chick or like that yeah
and then another thing that he wanted to
do that his son had to be like what was
he had this baby mannequin and he wanted
to cover it in blood and put it in the
trash can in the bathroom while he has a
prank guy but he was like you're gonna
get in trouble not only gonna get in
trouble no one's ever coming back to
this place and also this guy was like a
guy who was like you know a Christian
and like a woman's like like when I was
like a young
and I was a little bit younger he like
yelled at me one time we were all
playing on the trampoline I didn't know
any adults were outside and I cussed I
said a bad word do you remember what you
said I said the f-word but it was as a
joke or something it was like one of
those jokes were like hey watch your
[ __ ] mouth all right you know we were
like yeah you get it and he happened to
be out like on the deck and was like
Rand like he was like we don't swear in
this household like he was all but yeah
he want to put a bloody brush yeah Jesus
Christ
so and then after let's go steal a rod
after I left the thing that he this is
the craziest one the thing that he got
into after I left how long did you work
there I worked there for one summer okay
so not very long and after I left you
know it turned from a Chinese food
restaurant into now it's a restaurant it
was a deli there's a hot station and now
it's a full-blown restaurant the
standing guy when I left it turned into
a Cold Stone Creamery knockoff called
marble slab barbecue place right now
it's your growlers are yeah big jugs of
beer you can fill them there yeah so in
in Central Oregon and in Oregon and a
lot of places you know microbrew is the
thing and in Central Oregon there's tons
of breweries so they just have a whole
wall of taps and they got some laws
changed in Oregon actually where you can
go in and just fill up growlers and even
though it's not technically a bar you
can also still order like one pint and
sit there and have a pint
but yeah it's a growler fill up station
he's got like 60 beers on tap and you
just you know that's got to be crushing
it out with the yeah so he's he's kept
this business running all these years
from a thing open the never lost here's
another store in a town that's like 20
miles away and my friend from high
school I think is running that station
still the growler store yeah yeah you
know why you know why Oregon has so many
micro everything and is so craft well I
know one answer to that what's what are
you gonna say well it's Aras booze goes
the liquor laws in Oregon is you buy the
booze from the
governmental government owns all the
boots okay state the state yes so like
if you want to buy Absolut Vodka you're
not buying it from yeah like when you
own a bar and you order your booze you
get it a cheaper rate than people in
public again it you know I mean could
you buy a bulking you buy from the
distributors but in Oregon you're buying
it all from the government or the state
so you're paying the same price you
would pay if you bought a bottle off the
shelf in a liquor store mm-hmm well in
Oregon you have to buy at a liquor store
you can't buy it at a grocery store
right it's all run through the state so
then people started making all their own
stuff so they could cut off that
middleman and make a better profit on
their booze mm-hmm and blue I hosted a
bar show we went to Borland i watch no I
watched it I like I like that show I'm
really into that alcohol okay I like it
but I was gonna say I didn't know if
you're gonna say this in Oregon beer is
very popular because it's the same it's
one of the best places to grow hops so
like Germany and Oregon have the same
latitude in the same climate basically
and those are the two places where hops
grow the best and so that's where all
the beers coming from interesting yeah
so like you know people are having
breweries everywhere but they're still
having to get their hops from the same
location so Portland and Bend Oregon
have tons of breweries like my my town
is probably 25,000 people there's like
seven breweries Wow just in that town
and then in Bend am there's like 30
breweries music 80,000 it's that tire
from up there no I think that's Colorado
maybe is it Ned these two I just
remember when I was in Bend we would
ride bikes for my buddies place into
town and everybody was on bikes so I
don't know why that fat tire thing just
like pop yeah no bikes are pretty
popular and Lorien Deschutes Brewery
that's probably the most popular and
just shoots yeah but uh so so hey I'll
get to it now finally the craziest thing
that's all I'm not even there no no I
that that's how's the business change a
little bit but one of the things that he
got super into after I left was launch
air ballooning so he would attach big
balloons to lawn chairs and float away
anyway yeah yeah I've seen any videos of
people like you put whatever like eight
or ten but whatever it takes on your
chair so and it'll float you up no
helium balloons like the big balloons
they put on like car Lots uh-huh and he
you know he bought like at one of those
nice reclinable chairs and he worked he
did a lot of work and figured out the
best that's not no I thought he was in
this lawn chair I mean it's a lawn chair
but it's like one of those like
zero-gravity lawn chairs and assuming
and he he tried it out two or three
times until he finally was super like
his goal was to float from Central
Oregon out of the out of the parking lot
of the gap how high like like right now
he is dealing with legal trouble because
he was in airspace he was interested in
like he was a seat belt or anything yeah
he would wear and his goal was to float
yeah he would float from the parking lot
of the gas station for a promotion and
then his goal was to go over the Blue
Mountains into Idaho which is a very
long way for to drive it it takes hours
and hours an hour so just just based on
the wind he thought this is where I will
go he tried it twice bailed you know the
chair got really low he jumped on the
chair the chair took off without him and
he would have his wife follow him in a
minivan as close as she could get on
roads we've had this poor lady with a
walkie-talkie and that and you know they
would stay in touch and stuff and he
finally did he finally took off landed
in hi-de-ho yeah how far that well are
we talking like 100 miles more than that
had to be wow I mean I would have to lay
he just he just went with the wind and
to let it go where it took him and he
made it to Idaho yeah yeah so all in
between like over you know like where
Evel Knievel failed to jump the make
river yeah so like that's in between
where we lived and where he ended up
because that hope that's the border of
Oregon
and and then for a couple weeks was on
every he was on Good Morning America he
was on when Jay Leno's still The Tonight
Show his name his name are we allowed to
say his name I mean he was on Good
Morning America yeah it's just look at
my look up launched air ballooning in
Oregon I mean is this a big thing that a
lot of people are doing no but I have
you know before he did this if you know
it was somewhat of a wives tale that you
hear about or you know I mean it was a
urban legend I guess that's them how was
he keeping the balloons attached to the
chair ropes yes and he had his his
method was he had a certain amount of
balloons that were low enough to him
that he could open and let a certain
amount out to lower instead of just
popping one at a time like you know
there's a story of a guy with a BB gun
and so he would just like let the air
out slowly and then he also had tanks of
water underneath his chair that he could
let water out to raise so he had this
whole system that he built himself we
tell you something about design of
thirst man I can't lose my tanks who
tell you something the Wright brothers
people thought that they were crazy like
helium balloons and stuff er what was
not I mean maybe at that point he was
but I remember because they know the
news stations would come I would I saw
the the video of it and he had all these
giant helium tanks getting loaded up and
then when he was on The Tonight Show
they actually set up his rig in the
parking lot and they took Jay Leno up in
it you know it was all like rope down so
yeah they go up so high and I know that
they like their goal was this guy is
gonna be one of those guests that is so
weird that he's funny you don't even
like a guy who kills on accident but
this guy like was trying to kill so it
was one of those yes where he tried to
make a joke about how his dick was big
and it fell flat what like he was like
go to the bathroom and he made some joke
about how you know if you're
well-endowed you just the guy who
everyone was just kind of like Kevin
Eubanks is like
yeah Bannen Fantana just right off of
that yeah but more recently he really
you know so he's how long has he been
doing this what this was just years I
don't think he's tried it since this was
since the fall well since he
accomplished it okay now once he
accomplishes something he moves on to
whatever else he wants to try to
accomplish but he is currently last time
I checked still having to deal with
legal issues because he was in this
airspace that he was not allowed to be
in so he is like getting in trouble like
what is your sighting penalty for the oh
really yeah yeah oh so once they saw the
tonight showing this and heard the story
they're like wait a minute you violated
a lot why don't you have to be caught
doing it I mean I don't know I mean
there's tons of pictures and I'll pull
the picture on my phone right now that
make you kind of be like oh holy [ __ ]
that's legit like so high in there
that's what I'm saying and he's just
cheer and balloons did he do promotion
for like the gas station get a banner
underneath the chair that was all for
the gas station like just dropping like
dim sum holy [ __ ] he had to learn how to
parachute - know what I mean crazy do
this like I'm gonna guess there's like
70 balloons so many [ __ ] right here I
want to see this it looks like a poster
for like I know those are the mountains
I grew up who took this picture
I'm probably a [ __ ] airplane or
something this guy is [ __ ] is I'm
telling this guy's a pioneer right here
I want to know like here's the other
thing you got to go up high enough that
if you do [ __ ] up your parachute has
time to open it you know what I mean
like you can't just go up a few hundred
feet you pull that thing it's oh you
just crashed on the ground was so crazy
I I mean I would pay first of all I
would love to have The Tonight Show to
be the hostess Tonight Show but it would
have been amazing to be I would love to
have interviewed him like so I mean what
else have you done like I sold Chinese
food I have a gas station man I got over
these mountains he's done it all I
started Mable mop marble top all of this
lemon it may have been a franchise
yeah I just remember specifically like
when Leno got up in the chair like all
he could say was this is stupid
give me I don't like this get me down
this is the stupidest thing I've ever
done like totally [ __ ] on it cuz he's
probably nervous yeah yeah but yeah so
that was like my boss as my first boss
dude I mean what an amazing guy my beer
cave yeah I bet it's still there I had
someone was driving through been someone
that was in LA stopped just to check out
the place and I'm pretty sure the the
beer cave still there so oh this was in
Bend ya know then I got a ask my buddy
Phil you can tell me it later on what
the name of the place yeah yeah because
I love this guy's about yeah interesting
guy he opened a couple more stores
I think his son is the one that's
running that current location but it's
not a gas station as well it is now the
other the new store isn't it's just a
market but this this place is a gas
station right and hilarious I think it
you got when when fans start hitting you
up about that picture you got off a
tweet definitely when an organ you can't
pump your own gas so like the other
thing as they you know he had all these
gas station attendants he made him dress
up kind of like they're from the 50s
they have to wear weird kind of like cap
and they they would wear a rag and yeah
and you know they had to wash I never
did I was in the doing [ __ ] man I get
somebody pump this gas and my friend cuz
it was my friend dad who owned it so
they would hire a lot of us and my other
friend that worked there his his secret
was he would go into the walk-in cooler
and like drink beer and then when he was
done with the beer he would just drop
the bottle and break it and just act
like like I am when they were moving
these beers and they must have broke one
so like every day he would just drinking
the cooler and just drop beer every day
broken beer always like to know what I
like you know one of my first business
ideas that when I was a kid growing up
is I wanted to make a gas station called
first class gas and do exactly what this
guy was doing I'm dressed up running out
there ding-ding-ding someone's hitting
the gas someone's hitting the tires
first class gasps man oh I guess yeah
service telling you this guy's ahead of
his time I had a good idea too but I
didn't have a name for it and I was
ahead of my time I just couldn't get the
funding but I was I can get that cash
I'm gonna get the I couldn't get the
bankroll going I was going as this is a
senior in high school or junior senior I
was the plan was to go to seniors who
couldn't get to the grocery store and
just do their grocery shopping and [ __ ]
for him dude he's senior nice-looking a
grocery store bro was not that one in
jail
not that one in jail that's true you
also said you had a pretty interesting
first job when you got here to LA that I
wanted to keep it about yeah so I you
know when I was in college I started
cooking in restaurants and for a while
it's why I thought I wanted to do I
wanted to open a restaurant or whatever
and I studied i minored in hospitality
business management in college because
what was your major my major end up
being like a socialist like a psychology
type degree cool I didn't want a major
in psychology because I was like well I
want to be a psychologist so I did I
took every psychology class and didn't
write a thesis and they gave me some
like social science you know yeah
they're just like I don't need it it's
need to get the [ __ ] out of here so my
first job in LA I was like it'll be easy
outs get like a job at a restaurant and
I applied it so many places and no one
would [ __ ] hire me they all wanted
kids who were just out of culinary
school not not guys that had minors in
college or guys who had like lots of
cooking experience actually working in
restaurants were area grads making
Chinese man baby that wasn't that was my
first job I didn't cook in that job but
you know I cooked in in a lot of
restaurants in college and before I
moved to LA I moved back to my hometown
and cooked there for a while and yeah I
mean looking back I probably wasn't as
good as I thought I was I'm a better
cook now but no one would [ __ ] hire
me I finally I finally got a job and it
was opening it hadn't opened yet it was
a place that you know new owners bought
and they hired me a week before they
opened and I was doing a lot of like
catering gigs I feel like this guy just
hired me and thought he was going to get
rid of
pretty quickly he just needed an extra
hand for a little while and then he
realized that I was like better than all
of the [ __ ] coronary school kids and
kept me and as I worked there for a week
we opened it was a restaurant bar and
opening day it was in West Hollywood and
it was Pride Festival that week and they
have a big giant parade and this place
was right on the parade route now Santa
Monica yeah yeah so they're like yeah
it's gonna be pretty nuts that day so
get you know look at the map figure how
to get here and so like opening night I
kind of peek out and I was like yeah
it's gonna be a big crazy gay party
probably I peek out and I and I didn't I
worked at a gay bar I didn't know it if
I looked at I thought it was just a bar
I didn't know anything right first you
know right interviewed no one's in there
well we interviewed for the job the guy
was like you know about West Hollywood
right I was like yeah I got here right I
mean traffic I was like oh all the
bartender's are wearing matching take do
you notice place is called the dick hole
a chef at the dick hole and they were
all like dancing and unison I was like I
work at a [ __ ] crazy who had no clue
he was working at a gay bar and so I
worked there for two years and like a
common you know get comic low
everything's like yeah like final that
was everything a gay no no it was like
this place was like you know trendy bar
food sliders and tacos and you know
whatever the guy I worked under was a
he's a [ __ ] idiot like so like this
the structure that it was like three
owners and they're pretty cool you know
they're different varying degrees of
being all right to me and then the guy
who was like the chef who was directly
my boss was just like such a bullshitter
and was hired as a consultant to like
get them ready for about a month but
they they're like we can't afford you
just we want you to hand over to someone
else so he was like now I want this job
so he had hired a guy like I drew
addict to hand over knowing full what
like knowing that this guy wouldn't be
able to do the job he like he was like
yeah when I leave this is yeah that's
running it and then they had to get rid
of him they're like I guess you'll have
to run it
he's like sweet and so like my first
like month the job I was dealing with
both of those guys the guy direct boss
he had a ponytail like the sides of his
head were shaved and he had a ponytail
down his back they had rubber bands that
went all the way yeah he had a big giant
soul patch and he drove like a
motorcycle and he was like our flame
shirts no but I mean like that type of
guy and working at a gay bar he really
wanted to mate let you know that he
wasn't gay and he would even say things
like I am the straightest guy in the
world like that doesn't mean anything
yeah and he would hit on all the
lesbians that would come in there he
would give him free food where I
couldn't even get free food and he'd be
like I cooked this he would like go
flirt with people and they'd be like
this is like our space get the [ __ ] out
of here
straight guy yeah and yeah so this guy
just had I I ended up starting a Twitter
account for his ponytail and I would
just tweet things that he would actually
say I didn't get a lot of followers but
I would say [ __ ] that he would say like
he'd be like like I I never blew this I
went out last night
this girl hot girl dude she came up to
me and she's like I'll give you $300 if
you cut your ponytail off what are you
kidding me like it's like yeah she's
making fun of you it's like her I told
her I was like I'm not cutting this
thing I've clearly I like it look at the
rubberband pretty cool story man or he's
like I made out with a billboard model
last like he does all these [ __ ]
weird stories and I was like you know I
was doing stand-up you know I moved to
LA to do stand-up and so I was the one
person that couldn't get a [ __ ] laugh
in that place like everyone else was
like cool with each other and they would
be laughing saying the stupidest [ __ ]
and I would chime in with one joke
everyone would go
silent I was like I am the [ __ ]
weirdo outcast of this group what the
[ __ ] how is that possible and then they
would listen to shitty music and I'd be
like ok I listen to some music I like
and everyone be like what is this [ __ ] I
was like only the coolest music that
everyone I know likes yeah like I was
the weird over there and yeah it was a
shitty job it was a but two years there
two years and you know I didn't I was
like paying my car insurance on a credit
card I was working like four days a week
six hour shifts like really you know I
you done stand-up before you move here
yeah yeah I did I moved to I don't even
understand for like six months before I
moved here but I had like a few things
that led me to believe that I was better
than I was
what do you mean well like do you member
Comedy Central did a thing called open
mic fight yeah and they've done things
similar so laugh riot yeah laughter I
was before that they did a thing a
couple years ago that they actually had
me and called up next you know it's
always it's like a web contest and they
have live shows and this year opened mic
fight I've been doing stand-up for like
a month you know and they were like
submit your videos and that's how they
were choosing they had eight cities
across the country that they were
considering people for and I sent I sent
a tape and I've been doing is my seventh
time on stage or something like that
sent it in and they chose me and so I
went to San Francisco and performed at
the punchline and and people were like
how long you've announced and I was like
oh you know like three months at this
point and they were like get the [ __ ]
out of here like people were mad yeah to
me like three months is a long time
right like when someone had been doing
Stan for two years I was like holy [ __ ]
that's crazy
and some people that were on that show
that I remember know Mandela was on the
show he won Alex Cole who's San
Francisco guy he lives in New York now
she need Garofalo know and then you know
a couple people that I don't think
really do stand up anymore
but uh I met you so I was there and I
kind of had like I froze on stage at one
point forgot everything that ever
existed and since you know ever since
then I've been a little
[ __ ] up from that one experience yeah
and I did good I think but I was totally
a different kind of a con stage we get
it dude you're 18 but I here's why I
wore backpack I wanted to do your puppet
in there I want to be weird and I had
this bit and I stand by it I would never
do it because I don't want to like get
labeled as this type of comic or
whatever I don't know I'm sure there's
people that do this that are great but
my last joke my last joke I would say I
would be like you know I was having a
conversation with comedian friend of
mine which is al I didn't know any
comedians at the way and he's like you
know we were talking about how what you
wear on stage is important and how you
know you know people will laugh at your
jokes if you're wearing if you're
dressed a certain way and I was like no
it's just however you want shouldn't
matter just just write good jokes and so
he challenged me he said tell joke maybe
it's not your best joke but tell a joke
change what you're wearing and then tell
the exact same joke and see what happens
and so I tell I tell us joke try think
what it was it was it was a joke about
zucchini bread so it was it was I don't
really like zucchini
I love zucchini bread so it makes me
wonder are there other things that I
don't like that might be good and bread
like cat bread because I don't like cats
and I would take my backpack off I would
open it up like I was gonna like take
something out of it and put it on but
then I would take my shirt off and then
put the shirt in the backpack and then
perform without a shirt on and I'm like
super hairy and I would just tell that
same joke I don't really like zucchini
and then like every lime that joke would
destroy and so that was like my big that
was my dish was just to the tea and I
would do it even slower I would just do
that whole joke and I'd be like so that
makes me wonder and every [ __ ] ride
would just kill Oh
and you know and and Joanne at Comedy
Central mm-hmm
they were the ones that were running it
and so like they talked to me afterwards
and I was all like you know I didn't win
I think it first or second that's there
was only two that moved on and they're
like oh you were great you were our
third pick and I was like yeah whatever
like I was just like yeah my shirt was
back on my parents drove you know they
came all the way from Oregon to San
Francisco to watch it they were so proud
of me and and yeah instead to this day
you know like I have a good relationship
with those two and I've kept in touch
and last time I don't know if they
remember I mean I knew you know but I
was like did you know that I'd only been
doing stand-up like for a month when you
chose me and they're like no I was like
yeah you guys [ __ ] up and then I
started worrying maybe they liked me
then more because it took a while you
know it took six more years since I
started getting things on TV this is
like how they [ __ ] liked me then not
now
totally but it's I mean if they know it
was only a month then you would have
been the product you they ever like what
signs kid to a deal yeah I had people
that were so mad at me they were like oh
really great right not okay well I've
been doing Stan for 12 years not only
have you been doing standing for one
month but your dad brings in a pine tree
yeah I don't have been on one stage
thanks for the Chinese food I'd only
done this open mic stage in Spokane
Washington the punchline was like the
second place I'd ever performed yeah the
second place ever yeah it was like you
know and there was like a big sign on
stage that's a Comedy Central and I had
to like sign a bunch of [ __ ] and get it
notarized this is like before they would
like just email you that [ __ ] they would
send you a big packet and it was just
like such a [ __ ] big deal to me yeah
for sure I was like yeah that's what I
want to do I want to be a comic so I
moved to LA and go cook in a gay bomb I
cook in a gay bar for two years quit
that job on on bad terms
oh yeah why didn't I didn't expect to
hear that well they wouldn't give me a
raise Nicole wouldn't give you a raise
they wouldn't they I needed a raise I
was doing a lot for them actually for a
while I was running the whole kitchen
behind my direct bosses back but
as they were losing money in the kitchen
and the owners came to me and they were
like what's going on here
I was like this is what's going on like
I you know he's a lot of food waste you
know I knew exactly why they were losing
he's buying lesbians [ __ ] cheeseburgers
every other goddamn night so they had me
calling the shots and via email and then
they would tell my boss what to do and
my boss would come to me and like this
is how we do things now they all like a
dick to me and it's like yeah I know I
that's my word I wrote that you [ __ ] and
the only raise they had given me was a
25 cent raise in two years and I was
like well now is the time to give me a
raise and they didn't so I was like just
so you know I'm looking for a different
job in the second I get that job I'm the
I'm out of here and even that's so
polite yeah tell you this right now I
want to give you notice so you can get
someone else but I'm [ __ ] out of here
guys should be looking for someone and
so I went to an interview and got this
job at a gelato store you were just like
I'm out well I started like I started
messing with coffee a lot like I got
really in the coffee and started
roasting my own coffee at home oh really
and so I knew everything and everything
but I knew a lot about coffee I just had
never worked on an espresso machine so a
lot of places wouldn't hire me as a
brief sticks had no experience but yet I
roasted my own coffee and I knew more
about coffee than a lot of the baristas
did except for how to physically use one
of those machines yeah so I got a job at
this place and the lady is like my son
is they have barista competitions and
her son got second in the nation that
year before and she's like he's gonna be
here for the next two months training
everybody so it was like this is great
yeah and they were gonna pay me way more
than the other place and I was like all
right so I'm hired she's like yeah
absolutely so I just like emailed my
bosses it was like 10:00 in the morning
I was supposed to be there at 11:00 at
the gay bar and I just emailed him and I
was like I've got a new job and have to
start immediately which was a lie
but it was just like not coming in yeah
and they were like they were [ __ ] mad
good cuz it's like in an hour right and
so I had the you know each owner kind of
email me tell me I was a dick mostly
only 1/2 of them were kind of cool one
of them was like [ __ ] you your dick and
then the
my direct boss text messaged me and
ponytail yeah so these act he texted me
and said thanks for sticking us with the
shift shift asked but he put a st so I
wrote what's asked improving that I was
in ask didn't didn't get back to me
after that I did bump into him I this is
a guy that I thought would maybe want to
throw a punch at me or something but
bumped into him years later just a
couple years ago
and he was like Randy he was driving up
in his truck honey tail yeah yeah still
had and me and Brendon Walsh and Johnny
Pemberton we had just got back from a
taping of The Price is Right and we were
all wearing matching shirts walking I
just saw him coming and Brendon knew
exactly who it was just from my
description of him and I was like oh hey
man but just like kept walking yeah I'm
not talking yeah and was the gelato
store the bomb you worked there for a
while and where you learned coffee
I learned the coffee used that to get an
even better job at a coffee kind of
general store it was like a hipster to
parlay door and then I was like the
coffee guy there then downtown Silver
Lake someone to I we have a mutual
friend that one time told me like I got
a friend he's like one of the best
baristas in the city were they talking
about you maybe I mean I haven't mmm I
haven't been doing that for a couple
years
okay then yeah I mean well blast we'll
talk about later
yeah I quit I quit that job two years
ago and then finally making money doing
you know it good for you man we're at
that time to man thank you so much for
coming on this was a lot of fun
will you please one more time to our
body where they can find you on your
podcast your your your special all o me
on Twitter at Randy lid key it's Li EDT
ke that's how you spell it
I'm hoping to get famous enough that you
can just type Randy L and a good
my name will boom I think it does that
on my computer but it might be split the
cookies better say listen to my podcast
the bone zone it's on all things comedy
you can go there you can go to bone zone
podcast.com and my album and half-hours
coming out October 10th Kearney Central
and the album will be everywhere you can
get albums love it man it's awesome
awesome graduates man thanks for coming
on thanks as always Jay Larson comma
calm Jay Larson comedy on all social
media Ryan Sickler on Twitter Instagram
Facebook Ryan Sickler calm we'll talk to
you all next Tuesday